So millennials are a generation,
we define them as having been born after
1980,
so the oldest of them is in his or her
early thirties.
The youngest mid teenagers,
typically generations last about 20
years or so.
We don't really know.
In the back half of this generation
ends.
That's probably a 12 or 13 year old
who's somebody different,
but he or she hasn't quite come of age
yet.
It's a very distinctive generation and
the oldest of them has now made the
passage into adulthood.
So we know a little bit more about them
than we did eight or 10 years ago when
they first came on the scene.
Distinctive.
They're very large generation.
By the time the 20 year cycle is done,
they'll probably be 80 million strong.
The largest generation since the baby
boomers,
they are very distinctive racially and
ethnically.
Uh,
they are the transitional generation in
an America that in the middle of the
last century was about 85 percent white
by the middle of this century will be
only a little more than 40 percent white
millennials are that are the most non
white generation.
There's more than four in 10 are
nonwhite.
Uh,
this is driven by the great modern
immigration wave that's now about four
or five decades old,
unlike our earlier immigration waves,
which are almost entirely from Europe.
This immigration wave is mostly from
Latin American,
Asian,
and it's the immigrants themselves,
but more so now it's the children of the
immigrants,
uh,
the US born children of the immigrants
who make up a very heavy portion of this
millennial generation.
They're just thinking distinctive
politically.
Uh,
they've now,
they're now old enough to an,
to a vote it in two or three
presidential elections.
And they were a very big part of both of
President Obama's victories,
uh,
by our calculation,
the Pew Research Center where I work and
did a lot of the research that led to
this book.
They are the most democratic voting,
a generation of young adults,
of any that we have seen in 50 years,
60 years of tracking,
of voting patterns.
Uh,
they're very liberal in their social and
cultural values.
So some of the changes that are going on
in the country on issues like same sex
marriage,
marijuana,
legalization,
actually pretty dramatic changes in a
fairly short period of time in terms of
public attitudes.
It's the millennials,
it's the young adults who are leading
the way,
despite their distinctive political and
social views and voting behaviors.
However,
they are not terribly attached to the
Democratic Party even though they gave
big votes the Democratic presidential
candidates.
Uh,
when we ask adults of all ages,
uh,
are you a Democrat or Republican or an
independent?
Millennials have 50 percent of
millennials say I'm independent.
We've never seen that high a share from
any age cohort.
We see a similar thing when we ask about
their religion or you know,
what are you?
Protestant,
Catholic,
Muslim,
Hindu,
Jewish,
a record share of millennials say on
nothing in particular.
And there's a third anchor institution
of society,
if you will,
that millennials are not attached to.
And that's a little old 5,000 year
institution called marriage.
Uh,
so of today's 18 to 33 year old is only
about a quarter are married.
If you go back to older generations,
they were the same age,
five and 10,
six and 10.
The oldest generation,
more than six and 10 were married.
I think the slow walk toward marriage
and the and the disassociation from
anchor institutions I think are
explained by first their economic
circumstances.
Another distinctive thing about this
generation is they're the first in
modern American history and perhaps the
first in American history that at least
so far we don't know how their story
ends,
but we know how the story of their
economic lives have begun and at least
so far,
they're the first generation in modern
times that is doing less well
economically than their parents'
generation on any way you measure it,
whether it's income,
whether it's wealth,
whether it's poverty,
whether it's employment,
unemployment,
all the classic measures and you correct
for inflation and you'll make it an
apples to apples comparison.
They're doing less well.
I.
The fact that they're doing less well
means a lot of them.
When we asked them who those were,
who aren't married,
would you like to marry almost seven in
10 say yes.
Why haven't you gotten married?
Well,
look at me,
you know,
I don't have a job,
I don't have a career,
I don't have the economic foundation to
get married.
Um,
and that will reverberate in interesting
ways as they mature into middle age and
beyond.
And then finally,
uh,
perhaps if not the most distinctive
thing about this generation,
certainly one of the most distinctive
things is they are first generation of
digital natives.
So they are the only age group of adults
now for whom those,
these amazing gadgets we now all hold in
our hand and we all take for granted
that with three clicks you can,
you can access the sum of all human
knowledge and frankly these days,
if it takes you a third click,
you're wondering what takes so long.
So somebody my age,
this is jaw dropping,
it's still jaw dropping every time I
access these information platforms and
do it in mobile sites.
And,
and I'm just amazed,
these young adults are not amazed.
It's the,
it's the only world they've ever known.
And,
and they,
they are carnivores in terms of their
habits with,
with these information systems,
not just for information acquisition,
but for the creation of networks.
They organize their social lives around
these networks.
They can build their own tribes.
Somebody more clever than me,
described them as a pri.
Copernican generation,
uh,
the universe really does revolve around
them because they can build their social
networks and they can place themselves
at the center of their social networks
because their social networks are built
around the things they care the most
about,
whether it's their hobbies,
whether it's their work,
whether it's the games I like to play,
whether it's information seeking in all
the rest.
This behavior has led some to suggest
that it's a narcissistic generation.
My own view is that that's a bum rap.
Uh,
I think it's all about the new platforms
and it's all about the human condition.
And if you have the ability to kind of
place yourself at the center of the
universe,
you will take it.
I think it's,
it's empowering.
It may lead to another trade of the
millennials.
They're somewhat distrustful of other
people.
And it may be because as they navigate
the online world,
it turns out not everybody is exactly
who they say they are.
And there's a,
there's a certain wariness about this
generation and I think there's an
interesting question about whether the
networks that they build online with
their,
the median millennial has a 250 a quote
unquote friends on facebook.
Somebody my age or older has only a one
fifth,
that amount of friends and many fewer of
us are on facebook.
So,
you know,
discuss among yourselves.
Has there been a quantum leap in human
friendliness,
uh,
over the fast few generations?
Or is it simply that the new platforms
create new behaviors?
Uh,
and,
and new ways of organizing your social
life?
It's clearly the latter.
I think an interesting question.
I don't think we know the answer to it
yet,
is as millennials age more into,
into middle age as they probably age
into some of the more traditional anchor
institutions of society,
marriage,
children,
home ownership and all the rest.
And these things are all happening more
slowly.
For millennials,
will they establish a more of an offline
network that begins to resemble the
networks and the affiliations and
associations that their parents and
grandparents at all?